Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How are you doing?
I'm doing fine.
Thank you.
Guess what I'm doing?
I don't know.
What are you doing?
I'm preparing breakfast.
I'm making scrambled eggs!
Do you know how to make it?
Of course. It's very easy.
First, beat two eggs with a fork.
Go on, please.
I'm listening.
In a pan, melt butter and cook the eggs over low heat.
That doesn't sound too difficult.
No, not at all.
Don't forget to keep stirring though.
Okay. What about chicken soup?
Do you know how to make it?
Sure!
Place chicken pieces in a large pot, then cover with water.
I can do that.
Boil for 15 to 20 minutes.
Do you have any vegetables?
Will carrots do?
Sure, that's good enough.
Add carrots and spices.
I usually use salt.
Do I have to boil again?
Just simmer for an hour and a half.
I should invite my friends over for dinner tonight.